لقيت الدنيا مقلوبه بقى فتحت التليفون
استغربت جدا اتفاجئت بقى من اللي حصل لقيت
الفيديو منتشر جدا في العالم كله
منورانا
[موسيقى]
هو بصراحه كان ده حلم حياه والدتي من زمان
انها كانت في يوم من الايام ده من كل شويه
تقول لي انا نفسي ابقى معاك على طياره
واحده في يوم من الايام بعد ما تشتغل وكده
انا لما لقيت الفرصه ان هي طلعت حج السنه
دي قلت دي انسب فرصه ان انا اعمل لها
المفاجاه دي واحقق لها حلمها وفي نفس
الوقت هي برضو كانت مسافره لوحدها بعد ما
عرفنا ميعاد سفرها
بعدها بيومين رحت قلت لها قلت لها ماما
معلش احنا للاسف انا مش هقدر ان انا اخد
الرحله ظروف
وهضطر ان انا بس هوصلك المطار وبعدين اطلع
على رحله ثانيه لو انا ما كنتش عايزها تشك
خالص في الموضوع وانا كمان كنت مش حاكي
لحد من اهلي خالص يعني والدي واخواتي
بحتتلهمش خالص ان انا عامل مفاجاه
[موسيقى]
والخضه بتاعتها
كانت لحظه حلوه جدا بصراحه يعني احلى لحظه
في حياتي ان انا فعلا يعني حسيت ساعتها ان
انا حققت حلم والدتي يعني انها تشوفني في
يوم القيامه على الطياره انا كنت مبسوط
جدا طلع الرحله وكنت متاكد انها مش مش
خايفه ان انا اللي طاير كنت عارف انها
واثقه فيا لانها يعني هي طول عمرها بتثق
في وكده
اتبسطت بصراحه من رد فعل الناس للفيديو
عشان كده هو يمكن عجب الناس عشان يعني دخل
قلبهم يعني اللحظه دي كانت
الناس انبسطت بيها
[موسيقى]